a leader who recognizes and rewards
feedback is going to encourage more
feedback so if I ask for feedback and
say I'm open to it and then somebody
gives it to me and I either defend
myself criticize them or or reject it
then I'm creating an environment in
which no one's going to give me feedback
or at least they won't give me honest
feedback they're just going to tell me
how great I am um whereas if somebody
gives me negative feedback I don't have
to listen to it I don't have to agree
with it but if I can encourage it I go
thank you tell me more go on yes thank
you oh this is is really helpful thank
you so the leader will create the
conditions and if people can see that
happen if they see a a young officer you
know and you by the way there's there's
a difference between respectful and
disrespectful feedback you know and to
maintain a spr of cor and and and and
and maintain the rank structure it can
be done respectfully sir can I give you
some feedback yes you can or can we do
it later or let's do it in my office
right as opposed to hey let me tell you
what I think that's disrespectful
because you're not evaluating the
situation that that maybe that officer
that more senior officer or NCO has in
mind so may I give you some feedback
asking permission is how it starts may I
give you some feedback and if they say
no okay then I know my place right but a
good a good leader a good NCO or a good
officer will want to receive it and
create conditions in which it's in which
it's welcomed and that then it'll get
encouraged and then what you're doing is
you're creating a culture of feedback
you know can you give me some feedback
of how I can improve oh you're great
well that's not true there's always room
for improvement can you please tell me
that I want that and again if the leader
asks for it instead of just waiting to
be to be given it the leader says I like
some feedback how I can do better um you
know and you create a form for it in
this meeting we're going to talk about
what we as an organization can do better
or how I can do better as a leader so I
want all of your answers and I've done
this with my organization where when you
have those
sessions um even if you agree or
disagree even if the leaders are
triggered you basically you're in
receiving mode go on tell me more and if
you don't understand you can ask
followup questions but please tell me
more go on yes and it's it's just taking
it all in right then the next day when
people have emptied their buckets then
you can say okay yesterday we talked
about what we can do better and what I
can do better now I want to talk about
where we can do better and what you
think you can do that we can improve
this and now it's all positivity and
moving forward because I've had the
opportunity in the Forum to get all the
junk out ready so to separate those two
I think it's very important to separate
the emptying of the bucket and the and
the looking forwards because you can't
do it in the same meeting it's too
there's too much emotion